you can make a pretty penny for those
masks nowadays they're sold out
everywhere I heard they don't worry I
heard they really don't they don't
protect against the coronavirus it's if
you're sick you're supposed to wear them
to not get other people sick yeah well
like that actually that's not bad it's
not bad if everybody have that on
because then if they have something they
keep it yeah here's the thing do we know
anybody besides Asians at Rock those
masts 24/7 at the airport people who's
starting to rock my yeah yeah but before
right just Asians of their property I
don't know who has corona more than
anybody all the nations do they yeah
damn Asians I feel like it's a racial
well dude I'm racist so I would okay
it's me and Nick like this when I swear
that Nick did wink a little they see a
little looser because Nick so to contra
chin stop where is shank of your first
corona victim man that you might have
that Corona I could see him having it
dude Corona yeah but a lot of people
have to do a lot of these everybody
these sand Christians they're getting it
yeah it's also known as the flu every
time dude they said it's killing
toddlers and see I don't think it's real
I'm gonna be real real real on it's
gonna Bravo right now dude look you
don't say i'm tripoli on a student i'm
going just regular bravo man okay i'm
going no i don't you think first of all
they said 3,000 people have it wait I
haven't seen anybody with it well
they're not gonna come into work Jen's
not here but okay
major chin has it maybe you don't ha
it's up you know it's up for debate he
says you just didn't get the call time
which I find hard to believe everybody
else got it Chin's usually pretty on
time in yeah very on time until you the
corona I mean I guess if we had to if
one of us had to get it definitely Jen
why are you looking at me well I'm just
looking to thinking about each person
and how much I would miss somebody over
there because I started with you and
then I just couldn't leave you
that's fair I feel like yeah who would
go I don't know man maybe well well I am
going to Europe soon that's true huh and
it's popping over there is it
oh yeah the things I'm doing answer them
definitely gonna get something oh that's
not coronavirus oh dude it's not
sexually transmitted you know what I
want to know for serious though in in
Asian community is there more of a fear
of Quran of our eyes to me it feels like
it's just a news thing it sounds that
real apparently according to a news
channel that sells advertising whether
they sell it huh well I mean they the
the commercials and well also the
government's canceled flights over
theirs and they can't come here we can't
go there so you think the airline's
won't lose all that money you know
you're that big of a conspiracy
well the airline wouldn't have a airline
because of legal reasons they have to
react if that's it because then if
somebody says that they get something
because of them so for legal reasons
they have to do that they're still
losing millions and millions upon
millions dollars every day you can't fly
there at all is that true do you guys
know anything you're not telling us
there's no I was supposed to go to Korea
in April when you're on uh on tour
uh-huh I was thinking about it okay and
then now that's like the second highest
thing ever right coronavirus but but
like are your family's like more worried
or something like I'll tell you if
they're over there they're super where
my parents are worried here they were
gonna go to Korea to stand there not
going well but also the the homeboy who
got it in Irvine it was the first case
in California got nerve Isaac oh your
iaugh aber who you guys talking about no
it was just was an older dude in a old
folks home but someone there him or his
daughter got back from China that's how
we got oh really that's crazy man but
what do they what I want to see a
picture of somebody that has it do we
have any images of someone that has it
what are we doing you can find him you
didn't see the Shah lot of people
falling down in China number yeah but
here's foaming-at-the-mouth
phone without the man that was a foam
party that's a movie a spring break I
think Jason Franco that's parasite
yes or nuts I'm just like wondering like
because cool co2 trying to find out go
to China they'll let me know how it goes
for you I went to China they don't seem
like they don't get I think under there
recently they could use a few less
people I'll be right here that's Jess
Kuroda it's just what we're gonna
transfer go right into King understand
because it's so applicable and we're
stepping all over it okay what's up my
dudes
Theo Brenda she said and it just got
believed Brandon what's up my dudes Theo
Brenda this is Tabitha I'm calling in
from Connecticut with a real timely King
understand it for you the coronavirus
everyone is freaking out about this [ __ ]
right now but what I want to know is
what you guys think about it do you
think that it's a real threat to
humanity
King eaters sing it love you guys Gang
Gang buzz buzz tabby huh
coming in hot there what do you really
think Brendan be honest because I feel
like something you're not even being
honest why I think I think Ron is
definitely real but I think this white
girl in Connecticut doesn't have to
worry about it I mean I think no it's
not gonna get there I think it's a [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's real it's a it's a
kinetic you know I won't get who's gonna
go to Connecticut no one goes there
somebody who shows you would free SPF
dude know what's gonna [ __ ] have you
been a heart for dude yeah man I've been
around okay I've been around it's real
I'm not conspiracy theory I don't I I
think here's the other thing though it's
not as scary as a lot of other stuff
like SARS and all that [ __ ] but it's a
problem for sure I I'm not on this guy's
like Oh government [ __ ] making this
up and you know go to China then go to
China let me know how it works out go to
China be fine
Go Go dude Snowden I would go to China
if I was going to China
oh yeah I can't you can't get there good
good I'm happy I can't go to China dude
I've been to China it's kind of whatever
yeah be honest I've heard I've heard
better and it's not really like you know
I don't think they're I mean it's it's a
tough place to be it's a lot of
bicycling it's a lot of balancing it's
basically like American Ninja Warrior
kind of practical time
you wanna get on the train
you have jumps up through some hoops
yeah dangling some cords yeah there's
people yes sleeping on top of other
people what yeah oh yeah some guys some
guys for guys are walking like in a line
and one dudes getting rest just we're
sleeping across their shoulder crazy
brother they don't there's no they got
it dude you walking in China bro you do
somebody dies on a sidewalk they make a
soup right there BAM
seven people have lunch and they keep it
cruising they're not they're ready
hottest not like an individual type of
place it's not like who are you who is
this it's just moving yeah you're seeing
the way they get into trains where they
shove each other then one day the
biggest dude will open his mouth two
people will jump in the mouth like a
grouper fish oh yeah get out of a cheer
Jing the coronavirus that's what I say
if it's real or not we don't know but
we're gonna sting it but I think you
until I lose until somebody until we
really lose somebody and you see
somebody go down from it that's when I
think we'll get concerned and that's
when I think shits gonna really hit the
fan so that's why I think you got to
have a weapon you got to have a little
bit of something at the house to take
care of yourself you need a first aid
kit you need a thing of potatoes a bag
of potatoes or some casserole yeah a
casserole cuz she could get heated bro
you know we need somebody we know to
catch this virus see how real it is yeah
80% of people get it survived though
mild symptoms yeah educate yourself
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]